[Music]
today's question comes from kinsey in
utah my husband and i recently are
recently married and debt-free our
household income is a bit over a hundred
k we recognize that we've been blessed
to be a blessing to others so we give it
pretty substantially out of our income
we're very committed to our church
and to giving resources to mission
efforts around the world as we talk
about buying a house in the next few
years we find it difficult to plan and
save when our heart
when when our heart is to give out of
our abundance
how do we find a good balance of giving
generously and planning for our future
that's a great question kenzie what a
great heart i was about to say you sound
amazing
um well
you know there's
there's kind of this this
way of looking at giving in two buckets
i think there's
a little bit more of kind of the
emotional side right you you hear of
something
you're at something someone mentions
some amazing non-profit or something
then you're like and you think okay i
just want to write a check i just want
to give i want to give i want to give
right there in the moment and then
there's a that spontaneous you know
factor then there's more of the planned
giving where you say okay i'm going to
really map out and look at the places
that i give
research them making sure that they are
legitimate which i'm sure you guys have
done with your church and your the
efforts that you're giving to with
missions around the world um but you're
strategic on the amount too that you say
okay here's our budget and here's what
we're going to give to so
neither one necessarily is right or
wrong i think that leaning toward that
planned giving though kinsey is what i
would encourage you to do to say hey sit
down and actually put numbers to what's
going on because if you are budgeting
and you guys are debt free so you're
going to be able to have more margin to
give which is amazing and to say okay we
want to give
i don't i don't care what it is 20 25
10 12 whatever you guys
feel like okay this is a good amount for
us to give
and plan that and then say okay out of
that and out of our budget how much do
we have to save for a down payment on a
home and then just map it out over the
next couple of years and see where that
gets you
because
both are great
saving up for a down payment on home is
awesome and giving generously is amazing
but you guys need to put a little bit
more detailed
um planning around it so that you can
make both happen instead of kind of just
it sounds a little bit on a whim some of
your giving
i would be a little bit more detailed
with it but i i want to reframe
right now in your mind i want to reframe
your your paradigm on this kenzie
because right now in your mind the way
you describe this
it's as if buying a house feels selfish
and
counterproductive because that money
could be used for generosity
and it feels like these two things are
competing with each other
and i don't think that's a correct i
don't think that's real what's real is
buying a house will cause you to become
wealthier
than renting
if you rent your entire life you're
going to have less money than if you buy
a house
because rent goes up every year
when you buy a house the house goes up
and it becomes an asset and
you've stabilized and locked in your
housing cost it's not going up every
year
other than taxes and insurance might go
up but i mean the the cost of
the biggest cost you have is your
residence where you're going to stay you
know and so
if you want to give more
the the best way to give more is to
build more wealth
and stabilizing your housing cost
is going to cause you to build more
wealth so they're not working against
each other long term
they might be this month
or they might be over a year while
you're trying to get into the house and
it's more expensive than where you are
now it might be right then but over the
course of 40 years or 30 years
owning a house is going to cause you to
be able to be more generous and so let's
not let's not frame this that these two
things are competing
but if you pan back with a long enough
lens on this you will see that buying a
house is going to cause you to be able
to be more generous i'll give an example
okay
i don't have a house payment rachel
didn't have a house payment
we can be more generous than somebody
that has rent
you know it's pretty simple so uh you
know you just don't have that big hairy
payment that most people have got you
know it's a couple thousand dollars and
most people's budget a month or 1500
bucks a month or whatever it is in most
people's budget that we don't have and
so you can that's money we've got that's
free to invest and
or to give yes and there's nothing
unholy about planning either
right because there's a little bit too
the mind of man plans his ways and the
lord directs his steps yeah yeah
scripture says that so there's a there's
a level of being a good steward in this
two kenzie of you guys sitting down and
actually planning what's happening yeah
and
you know i we plan our impulses
i mean it's we leave some we plan a line
item in the ramsey family foundation
budget annually to do some giving that
we don't know what it is yet
yeah and so we've planned it but and
then we've got certain ministries and
things that we are supporting that we
very definitely lay down there but we
leave some margin in there for
things that are going to come our way
that we don't know yet yes and so that's
planning your impulse i mean it's kind
of funny but it's very true it's what we
do
good stuff